it just does not stop Target we've got
some info here from the daily wire
Target donates to group that promotes
secret child gender transitions lgbtq
books in schools a little info on that
Target has repeatedly boasted about
efforts to support the gay lesbian and
straight education Network known as
glsen so they then put money into
pushing all of this gender ideology and
gender transitioning of what they call
gender affirming care which I often
point out is the least affirming thing
that you can do when you're chopping off
someone's genitals but it does not stop
and again this is all about kids it is
not about adults
[Music]